i don't think there's a lot of
originality
in the stories there's originality in
how they're told
would you say filmmakers today are more
concerned with forcing a message than
telling a good story
i see it
yeah i see it a lot um
and i i think
i think people are concerned
about
how they're portrayed instead of the
what the story's talking about
and um
which is
the you know people do what they need to
do that's not how i work
um
i have
no problem eating crow
if i have to
uh as long as i'm telling the story as
um
as truthfully and
from the heart as possible
but uh yeah i mean i i i see it a lot
where people are people are trying to
steer their
stories in a marketing way it's like oh
this is fresh
and they're like well i'm writing fresh
and i should never ever do that because
it just it reeks of um
inauthenticity but you know what there's
80 percent in in authentic films out
there that are making a ton of money so
i
i'm not right on that um a few
very successful careers are being made
uh it's just not how i do it so it's uh
it's it's not how i approach it and it's
not
how i want to consume it i don't want um
i i nev i i preached
door to door
knocking on doors with the word of
jehovah for 20 years of my life
the last thing i ever want to do is
preach even if i believe in something i
don't want my belief system
to
um
to find its way into the story and push
it on the viewer i always want the
viewer or the reader
to
have their own questions and come up
with and go
oh that's interesting i'm not sure if
that
blank i'm not sure if blank i don't i
don't want them to know
the most beautiful compliment i got when
confessions of a teenage jesus jerk came
out the film
was
they people thought i was still the
jehovah's witness
and i was just like yeah i did it right
because yeah i
i do not believe in that belief system
at all it's very corrupt and it's
it's not good um
but when i'm telling the story
my message can't be in there i could
tell i could tell the world of
but i love it that people aren't sure
if i'm still affiliated with the
religion or not that's the greatest
compliment and i feel like that should
be
i would love that to be across the board
where someone i don't want to know their
political affiliation i don't want to i
don't want the film or the story to tell
me
where they are
i want i want them to explore the human
condition because that's what we all got
so
you said something to the effect of 80
of movies nowadays
do seem to
fall into a category of a message
they're doing quite well
who do you think the audience is
for those films
um
i mean it's
it's interesting because i don't i don't
think the audience this is why hollywood
is a weird business because i don't
think the audience is too critical of
certain things
because the general audience is there
just to be entertained
what are we doing on saturday night
honey we're going to the cinema cineplex
well who's what's there i don't know but
that cute guy in that films in this film
well great let's go
and they go and then they enjoy it and
then they go home they're they're
and their enjoyment of it is great well
great that's that's that's what it's for
what uh
even if it has a message what a great
gift that those filmmakers gave to those
people who got to go on a date and then
got to go home and cuddle and just you
know come together because they saw a
movie that i wouldn't necessarily
care to see so
the viewership is just so vast that i
you know i i don't want to make a
judgment on those people
um i just i'm just uh
you know i and those people do not want
to see my movie i mean and they've been
vocal about it on the internet so it's
just like you know i turned that off
after five minutes because what this
this and this and i'm like
you know
yeah it's not for you that's fine
i because i don't write for everybody i
never want to write for everybody i i
want
that i want people
to not like me and i'll feel like i'm
doing a
i want people to like me of course but i
do want a certain population to not like
what i'm doing
because
then it then i know i'm um
then i know i'm hitting the authenticity
and i'm hitting the truth
and
there's and you know and sometimes i
disgust myself i'm just you know i'm
just like
it's probably it's probably why i can't
read my old work or you know watch old
stuff is
it's just too much because i'm it's just
too much uh
not that it's bad not that i don't know
that i don't think it's good it's just
it's too much to consume
on my own as like a reader or a writer
or as a viewer
it's uh
it's it's weird yeah
the you know like familiarity breeds
contempt so you're you're too much of
your s you know how we all see ourselves
in a different light not not not
contempt i think it's just um
that was a point in time and and that's
and that's all that and that's what it
was and
how lucky am i
but i'd rather watch a new episode of
money heist on uh netflix
um
you know it's uh
yeah i don't know i don't even know why
i said that i have therapy at 10 am
tomorrow i could talk to
my therapist about it okay no i mean i
get it i mean some people after a while
they're like okay i'm glad i've passed
this phase i don't want to
live here anymore in this like mindset
so
i i can understand that yeah it's yeah
yeah with so many remakes and reboots
being made today how can creators truly
tell original stories
well yeah i don't i i get the franchise
thing you know oh aquaman worked
and people know what aquaman is
um
a whopper works they're gonna go buy a
whopper instead of the hamburger at the
local mom paw joint because they don't
know what that is
um
i i think
i don't think there's a lot of
originality
in the stories there's originality in
how they're told
and
the originality of how
we're bringing our unique
um voice
and uh to what a story that's already
been told over and over again
and then we get and then we get together
with uh
the actors who have their own unique
ways of working and then the directors
have their unique ways of working
and that's where the beauty comes or
that's where it totally flops and dies
but um
yeah i mean for the reboots you know
they got to make reboots so they can
give money to the stuff that maybe
someone cares about i guess
and actors even got to do it too i don't
think
any of these actors that work in
superhero movies i i don't think they
really want to but that paycheck's
really good and it's just like i'm going
to get in that cost them again
and you know it's and i would get in the
costume too because
who wouldn't want to buy a house in los
feliz
sure the palisades all right private
schools and yeah exactly it's it's great
decision making so
um yeah i don't think i'm getting hired
on any of those as a writer
uh but may you know maybe maybe they
want someone contrarian to come in
so
sure
have you seen any remakes that were
actually better than the originals well
ocean's 11 for sure um
was just way better than the train wreck
that was the frank sinatra
uh
rat pack ocean's 11. um
let me try to think of uh
some arrays some remakes that were
better than the originals i don't know
it does happen sometimes
um
i i think uh
it's a it's there's a there's a
narrative where they try to take great
films from the past and remake them now
i think they should go for the crappy
films in the past and remake them i
would love to see remakes of terrible
films like what how i don't know uh
maybe a hard r version a parent trap
no
i i don't know
why was ocean's 11 why was the first one
so horrible
i well i've only seen it once i don't
know if have you seen it
not not the you said the one with frank
sinatra yeah yeah yeah the rat packs are
yeah it's um
they didn't care i don't think there was
any
care taken in it it's like we got these
stars let's put them together uh
when it got to
uh sodenberg
seems like there was care taken
you can tell
there's um
there's
it's
you know it's a blockbuster film but you
look at the frame by frame and you and
you look at
the decisions that were made
and it's just like
every decision is a great decision is
you know it's uh
the the there's a lot of little elements
in there too i can't remember who wrote
the screenplay but
the the beautiful little elements and
little choices that are made
that's it's it's it's what
just brings it all together yeah
what classic film it would be a travesty
if they tried to remake it today it
would just be insulting
oh i don't know
i don't know i think everything should
be given a try
i mean
gus van's aunt did a try on psycho
which was just awful
it's like vince vaughn was um
yeah i know it's nobody remembers it
there's a reason it's because it was
terrible and i think they used the exact
same script
you know and uh it was yeah but
give it a try why not i mean
hey people you know it's if someone's
gonna
hey i'll write a remake of something
i'll i'll write a remake of a great
movie
and hope i can do better and then
everyone can just dirt on it
and
you know i
yeah it's
i say have fun with it i say i say ruin
great films
why ruin them well i mean if you're
going to remake them
yes
it's it's it's a canvas it's like it's
it's it's uh
you know
why why not go ahead and try to
re-sketch it
and and i hate this word intellectual
property but it's all about oh we have
this property let's renew this property
and let's make money on it and i
understand the business sense of it
so um
not that i'm going to run out and
be excited that they remake a you know a
certain film like
you know the bicycle thief or whatever
is you know it's like let's remake it in
modern day los angeles um you know what
go ahead actually
um
it's yeah it's uh
there's so there's so much crap being
made it doesn't matter if more crap's
made i guess um
okay yeah what if i take music though
which i know is near and dear to your
heart as well some some you know like
you said uh was it on camera or off
camera public image limited was one of
your first concerts that you went to
okay so pil what if there was a band
that was trying to remake all those
songs and there was a johnny rotten that
was the new the new guy wasn't johnny
rotten but it was like this new
influencer guy
they kind of looked like johnny rotten
and had sort of the same sensibility
justin timberlake can remake it i'll be
like oh let's see if it's good okay yeah
i i guess i guess i'm not nostalgic
about it um
i've already had my experience with uh
the the either the original film or
seeing the original band and um
yeah so
um
i i don't say i i'm i'm realizing now
that i'm not really nostalgic if
somebody tries to remake something i'm
like go ahead do it
they can remake jesus jerk and make it a
uh you know make it a superhero film and
you know just send me the check
okay
why do you think people though are so
precious
about some of these films
or adaptations of certain books well
like why are why are some people so
adamant that it shouldn't be done that
it
you know because there are fans that
would that are that are angry that the
original work
yeah i guess they attribute meaning to
it and meaning to it in their own lives
um
but it's
i i don't know if they uh if they work
in film or if they are writers
uh they could be uh
you know and and with writing you know
and
film is it's meant to be critiqued it's
meant to be just ripped apart that's
what
everyone's supposed to do that's
the that's the beauty of
of all of it it's you're having a
conversation about it great it's it's
creates continuing the conversation
so um
yeah i mean it's you know it's um
there was like what was that rocking
rock and roll high school the ramones
were in rock and roll high school then
they had rock and roll high school too
corey feldman was the ba it was the band
of rock and roll high school too
and um you know people hate it but i get
a kick out of it i'm like there's corey
feldman pretending like he's michael
jackson it's just like
it uh
i'm not upset about it uh because
there's the first one that meant a lot
to me as a kid and uh the second one is
corey feldman
pretending like he's michael jackson
sure and the ramones were
at the height of their stardom when that
you know i think they gained more
stardom i think after that movie came
out i think that's
yeah
i think they i don't think they realized
that was going to put them to a new
level
but i don't know i can't remember
because i can't remember exactly when
the movie came out
why i saw it on vhs oh nice